appelez un [ __ ] de voleur dans mon hé, faites tomber
cette merde en ce moment l'un l'autre,
allez vous faire [ __ ] pour moi ouais tu veux aller bien cool
énervé juste officier cet événement aujourd'hui
monsieur j'étais juste j'essayais d'être
sûr de ce que tu fous encore
ici de toute façon non je pensais monsieur je pensais que
vous aviez dit Seigneur Tout-Puissant que vous avez évolué
a Darwin lui-même venu à Orlando en
Floride bien la caution sera là à temps
mr.  Carver allez-y oui d'accord d'
accord allez vamanos Freddie allons-y
ouais les gars quelle vue sur les lacs on y va
et vous monsieur avez-vous fini parce que j'ai
les flics sur la numérotation rapide ils peuvent
vous chasser hors de la ville sur le feu arrière éclaté
I '  je suis ici pour me battre bien c'est bien je suis
venu ici pour récupérer mes outils et vos gars ont
volé l'air d'un éclat où je ne
m'occupe pas de non comme je l'ai dit hier je
comprends ce que vous dites ouais vous
comprenez ce que vous faites nous m'avons donné
hier  expulsez-moi oui je ne
vous ai pas expulsé de la banque est-ce que je viens de représenter
Richard Carver ce que vous m'avez obtenu privilège kiddo
ouais merde hazmat je vais m'appeler 914
shader drive maintenant qu'en est-il d'être un mouvement
oui monsieur allez mr.  Carver désolé d'interrompre
ta journée toi Miguel qu'est-ce que tu travailles tu as des
outils tu fais de la construction ouais je
travaille 914 shader drive je paierai cinquante
dollars en espèces qu'est-ce que tu plaisantes de moi
cinquante dollars va être une blague pour toi fils